[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello,
and welcome to I/O Live.
I'm Florina
Muntenescu, your host.
And I'm here with Haris,
product manager on Android Auto.
Hi, Haris.
HARIS RAMIC: Hi, Florina.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: So tell me.
What's new for developers
for Android Auto?
HARIS RAMIC: So this is
a very exciting year.
We have all the new sets
of the changes in the API
for media and
messaging developers,
which is the biggest change
we made in a long while.
For the media, what the
developers can do is,
they're going to be able to
do content browse forward,
which is pretty exciting.
And they're going to have
different sets of layouts
that they can use to actually
present their content better
to the user.
For the messaging, we
have new messaging styles
which is going to
enable them to do,
for example, group chat and
a couple of different things.
And for all the
thousands of developers
that we have for Android
Auto, that's pretty exciting.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Am I
able to already download
the apps directly in the car?
HARIS RAMIC: Yeah, so
actually what we have right
now is we're also showcasing
the preview of the Play Store
Google Assistant
in the vehicles.
So we've announced
today that we're
going to be shipping some
of these Google services
with Volvo.
So that's pretty exciting.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Anything
else that you want to tell us?
HARIS RAMIC: I would say, keep
developing for Android Auto.
If you're media/messaging apps,
we're excited to work with you.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Perfect.
Check out the documentation
that we have online,
and start developing
Android apps.
Thank you.
HARIS RAMIC: Thanks.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: This
is Florina for I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]